hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to let's
talk about inspector gasps he was a show
in the 1980s about a half human half
robot detective no this one was funny
intentionally funny it centered around
the inspectors bumbling antics to stop a
super villain named dr. claw while
gadgets youngmee's penny and a dog named
brain would go behind his back and solve
the crime for him it wasn't anything
special but for kids it wasn't that bad
it had a smart humble role model who
never got the credit but was just happy
to see justice done it had a menacing
villain you never saw who had a pretty
intimidating voice well what a
delightful surprise and of course it had
that kick-ass hole
[Music]
doing a movie on this premise however
will be tricky but not impossible great
care would have to be taken let's see um
let's get that idiom who said that's a
lot of fish from Godzilla and while
we're at it why don't we get that moron
who ruined Madonna's career no the other
one there you go and finally let's get
one of the greatest directors of all
time the one who directed the
coming-of-age classic cool as ice ice
melts if that trio of idiots wasn't
enough this movie has horrible writing
terrible jokes and follows the show
about as closely as well
casting John Leguizamo as Luigi I mean
it's bad this shit is really really bad
so don't go catch it fuck a movie
because we're ever quite an experience
this is Inspector Gadget so as the film
begins I have to admit it is pretty cool
hearing the theme song in a motion
picture
[Music]
that quickly changes when we see the
cock face himself Matthew Broderick he
doesn't even said anything and already I
hate it we see this annoying dream
sequence where he saves a bus of kids
from danger when we suddenly cut the
cliche number five six to one thinking
you're kissing a woman when really
you're kissing an animal go-go-gadget
react brain having another hero cop 3
what goes on by the way this is penny
everybody yeah the GU need to get a
blonde girl play the part they said two
years as a security guard isn't enough
experience to be a cop Uncle John I'm
sorry and of course just like in the
show her parents are not around and thus
uncle gadget known right now as uncle
Brown is left alone to take care of her
this is brain he looks nothing like the
cartoon doesn't talk so let's move on
smell the badge it's the heart behind it
[Music]
I'm very proud of you well what the hell
is that
well nothing anyone we're not gonna
address that okay we'll just come back
to that later we see a scientist played
by odo from deep space 9 and his
daughter Brenda as they're trying to
work on a new invention that can control
robotic limbs by the power of the mind
tap your foot again what what were you
thinking about it I was thinking about
how much you remind me of your mother
that's it it's animated by will not by
thought by your heart not your head oh I
see so it's love that fuels scientific
mental animatronic limb repair oh and
this just in believing in fairies can
regenerate dead tissue back to life as
well what the hell is that well why did
something random things popping up in
the same way unless those are the
segways okay
film on oh one guys when you do a
transition you want something that
actually transitions not incredibly
distracts from everything you see guys
when you do something this annoying and
this distracting it doesn't add to the
style it just takes away from the story
but little there is I mean if you're
gonna go that far why not just go all
the way why don't you do this
[Music]
so Brown it turns out as a security
guard at the doctor's place and often
makes chitchat with the doctor's
daughter Brenda but little do they know
that the evil doctor claw is watching
and ready to steal the robotic foot for
his own diabolical deeds
maybe he's hoping to start an
animatronic kickball team he's that's
the doctor eyes famous guest shot and
edited by a monkey and brenda comes
across the lab and sees what happened
dr. Bradford I won't rest until I find
whoever's responsible justice will be
served
look at that I almost pulled out of my
wide-eyed blandness and delivered an
actual human emotion but I pulled back
into the blandness just in time oh
that's too much motion just in time so
Brown goes after the bad guys to see if
he can make justice prevail
Oh No we've been chased by the hatchback
squad were you needing to keep dr. claw
in the shadows because you are aware
you're revealing it quite clearly right
now
now he's back in the shadows again are
we just supposed to forget you revealed
it right there
I mean we saw it there's no surprise now
we know what he looks like
why put it back in the shadows if you
just showed his face I mean it's sort of
like starting off the original Star Wars
movie with the Imperial Senate will not
still do this when they hear you've
attacked a diplomat back to me of lady
that is no way to speak to your father
oh shit you're not supposed to know that
yet um just forget that part everybody
totally knots important Carrie help good
good come with that take her away
dodged a bullet
[Laughter]
[Music]
because so dr. claw finally reveals
himself again and uses an explosive to
blow him up remember smoking kills I
[Music]
mention to the cartoon that dr. claw
never reveals himself and even if he did
would this be at all what you imagine he
looked like I imagine he looks like a
monster I imagine he looks like a
machine I imagine he looks like that gay
guy from my best friend's wedding no
enough
so the explosion leaves Brown about his
brokenness is acting Brenda makes a plea
that he always thinks with his heart so
he'd be perfect for their weird-ass
little robot operation thus all the
doctors come together to put mr. Brown
back together loading with cartoon sound
effects
[Music]
we see the claw actually has a claw now
so he decides to give himself that name
yeah I forgot to mention his name wasn't
actually claw this whole time he was
sanford scolex just call one word like
madonna so let's just recap vector claws
and call doctor claw he doesn't own a
terrorist organisation called mad he
sounds less like a monster and more like
a fetching critic and the fact that you
never see him in the show is being
replaced with seeing him all the time I
mean wow did they get one thing right
why did you change so much were you
afraid if you stuck too closely to the
cartoon that wouldn't be taken as
seriously
neither remind you this movie has scenes
like this yeah wouldn't want to face
that so Brown wakes up and finds that
his entire body is laced with and let's
be fair here mostly pointless shit yeah
you never know we might need a balloon
or bubbles there's no security guards
looking after this walking human atom
bomb just let him press the nuclear
button he'll be fine
what's around you've just come out of a
very long recovery you are now a
sophisticated network of tissue hardware
and software no I gotta get out of here
God is he bad I'm sorry
this guy's a marvel truly a gift to bad
acting it's like he never knows which
delivery to give so he sort of starts
halfway and decides to maybe go with
another one maybe no I gotta get out of
here no I gotta get out of here I know
that this is all new for you
and it must feel strange by the way here
those really annoying sound effects that
won't shut the fuck up yeah get used to
that people it's all throughout the
movie
it's like he's wild gerald mcboing boing
or something no
so Brenda explains to him exactly how he
functions and he'll they'll be able to
keep him alive it's a high-powered
processor chip that increases the charge
in the human brain wave enough to move
the machinery that's now built into your
body but we still can't make you act
without this chip your body couldn't
possibly function any more questions
nope then I will just give you your
manual to study heart of gold everybody
he's so innocent that he actually makes
monkey sounds whatever he sees a woman's
behind can't go gadget hard ah no she
continues to show him how his junk works
and oddly enough that's not as
disturbing as it sounds and Brown tries
to get the hang of it there were two
guys trying to rob a jewelry store and
you wanted to trip him up what would you
do go go gadget oil slick
okay why would anyone put that much
toothpaste inside of him I mean how many
emergencies require toothpaste and why
hose is there really a situation where
you need to shoot toothpaste from the
hose and why did they come out when he
said oil slick
what can we see dr. Claude sorry I'm
still on that
so he's introduced to his new set of
wheels a convertible and just to ante up
the annoyance in this film the proud
enough to have the car voiced by DL
Hughley
oh what a delight good morning riveted
[Applause]
not the gadgetmobile guess it could be
worse they could be having Chris Tucker
doing the voice in the car
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's a Disney movie oh did you see that
a subtle little wink to the audience to
show that it's aware it's a Disney movie
and of course when I say a subtle little
wink I mean a fatal stab into the eye
when I'm talking salad park rookie
thinking he's good enough for dr. B
that's Bennet any of your business
what makes you think our win is mine now
why are we in his mind all right now
we're back in the car okay now we're
back in his mind hey I got an idea
it's doesn't showing us those extra
scenes you shot for the movie but had
nowhere else to put them why don't you
focus on something useful like I don't
know giving us to the fucking end
credits no clue so not a class so to
come across a couple of criminals trying
to steal a car but Brown of course
thinks they lock themselves out it
actually helps them to steal it here
just how to do it all right thanks truly
they made the right choice in making him
the world's first super cop imagine all
those intelligent hard-working officers
putting their lives at risk that don't
deserve such incredible powers a bunch
of hats what's the big idea we got us a
couple of jailbreakers well then we
should inform the prison guard
by the way just another pain to bring up
in this movie the editing is terrible I
mean awful some of the worst I've ever
seen like watch this shot oh did you see
that
how wrong was that one 1000 what is the
point of what he met shot in if you can
barely see it was there a subliminal
message that was trying to be snuck
through actually slowed down let's take
a look I know so they finally catch the
bad guys and Brown has claimed a cure
later that night he's invited to some
sort of celebration of the new
technology okay I mean really
you gotta put sound effects in even when
someone's getting tapped on the shoulder
what does it have how does it tell the
story any better hell maybe they're on
to something maybe Silence of the Lambs
would have been a lot more dramatic if
they added sound effects
[Music]
so close impressed with Brenda's where
can offers her a job to work with but
catch it doesn't trust him and
apparently doesn't recognize him seeing
how he clearly saw him blow up his car
so he sets up a listening device that
will no doubt lead to more irresistible
say Venus you know I think I figured out
the formula for this movie it took me a
while but I think I got it down poorly
edited slapstick followed by weird
wide-angle shot of some guy going ooh
and Matthew Patrick looking like an
idiot yeah let's try it let's see if
that works
slapstick pull idiot slapstick pull
idiot slapstick pull idiot well you
can't fault a formula when it works
except of course when it doesn't work
it's annoying as fuck when do I get
started on my big case I have a few
assignments really cut your teeth on
first
[Music]
so Brown gets his nickname Inspector
Gadget but still wants to get closer to
finding out who killed Brenda's father
he takes a look at the only clue from
the scene of the crime is he's a small
guy and printed on it but what else
could as I stand for space invaders
school burns right Oh what about that
scolex
industries oh well thank God that came
across that lorry knows it could be
anything else in the entire world
si what could it mean uncle gadget look
at that truck oh of course
Sports Illustrated they must have stolen
that foot for their brand new foot
finish edition oh wait automobile but it
turns out he's right as he finds the
foot heavily protected and tries to
break it out once again the formula
slapstick cool idiot oh did I forget to
mention in a comfortable void of nobody
laughing so Klaus shows him that he's
made another Inspector Gadget only this
one's evil and surprisingly and even
worse performance
lots or loss of fees
as he wreaks havoc on the city dr. klahn
removes the chip that keeps catching
alive taking away his only means of
breathing goodbye mister by the way am I
the only one that thinks broderick dead
looks exactly the same as Broderick
alive I don't think so
so penny Brenda locate him in the
junkyard and tried to see if they can
bring him back to life
an estate chip is gone it is neat it's
got the part do it all by himself
well bye let me know how that all turns
out
[Applause]
hmm John John can you hear us
she's a lot even though it defies
everything logical at everything
scientific Inspector Gadget comes back
to life sibling for the will of heart
I said simply for the will of heart
simply throw em apart excuse me Jane
Aspen you're so French really witty and
the head of no time free
so the team gets together to stop dr.
Clough first they drop off penny yeah
cuz it's not like she did much in the
show and they tracked out dr. Klaus Lim
you're under arrest for the murder of
Artemus Bradford scolex god you're
irritating I actually think that was the
critics quote on the DVD so the two
gadgets pull out of the car and have a
fight with each other it's pretty lame
and not the least bit funny but no
there's nobody after that we shouldn't
be fighting we've got a lot in common
said that I've got nicety I hope that we
could work together been partners
together you and I could have ruled the
world of cool down river so he tosses
the villain into the ocean right before
saying oh let me guess you should have
your head and goes out there dr. claw
who of course has captured Brenda
yeah I'm sorry I still can't get over
how much this guy has nothing to do with
dr. claw the main villain of the show he
seems more like one of dr. claws
henchman than he does the actual
mastermind what are you doing you're
supposed to be disposing of gadget are
sit back and relax darling well how dare
you so as you'd imagine gadget gets
Brenda off the helicopter and claw
Jack's himself just to be caught by the
car I'll get you next time gadget Jesus
you know if you want a movie that's
actually more faithful to the essence of
the villain you'd be better off with
this it's not cold Oh Oh the claws
coming at you oh you're scared of a claw
you're scared of the claw and thus we
finally end the movie thank God I don't
think I could take any more of them to
render all that your host okay now it's
the end of the trip
okay now it's the end of them oh come on
my name is Sykes okay now it's the end
of the movies i watch
it's a radio computer even a face brain
say something brain is not here complete
waste of a great talent but whatever
fine
at least now it's finally over oh my god
desperate you guys are really trying to
get at least one lap anything-anything
little piece of shit giggle you can
think up I mean really you're trying
everything you're trying every
last-minute piece of shit giggle that
you can get out of holistic oh you are
that needy for us to like something in
this movie well fuck you fuck you fuck
you the deferent is the perfect word to
describe this movie it throws every
bottom-of-the-barrel joke every overuse
sound effect every tired slapstick
routine and every over-the-top reaction
in the sad hopes of getting a laugh and
not one of them works not once it's
edited horribly it's acted horribly it
has little to do with the show and the
stuff that it does have to do with the
show it's a complete slap in the face
it's just crap total total crap and if I
were you and we'll go back to the video
story take your fucking money back don't
go gadget refund I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember so you don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a TV movie